Senator Ted Cruz
and his Democrat colleague Senator Joe
manchin
have just saved your gas stove yes Crews
and Mansion introduced legislation to
prevent the federal government from
Banning gas-powered stoves now what
you're going to hear from the libs who
are going to try to poo poo all of this
just the same way they say oh the Spy
balloons come over our country all the
time oh myocarditis that happens all the
time what they're going to say is
nobody's trying to ban your gas stove
this is a political
right-wing fever dream no it's not true
here's the consumer product safety
commissioner a Richard trumka saying
just a couple of months ago that the
government would be looking into Banning
gas stoves
I think we need to be talking about
regulating gas stoves whether that's
drastically improving emissions or
Banning gas stoves entirely and I think
we ought to keep that possibility of a
band in mind as as you follow along
because it's a powerful tool in our
toolbox and it's a real possibility here
so this is not imagine this is not tin
foil hat this is really happening cruise
and Mansion say in a statement quote the
federal government has no business
telling American families how to cook
their dinner which is why Senator Cruz
and I introduced bipartisan legislation
to ensure Americans decide how to cook
in their own homes I can tell you the
last thing that would ever leave our
house is the gas stove we cook on and I
will continue to fight any overreach by
the consumer product safety commission
this is really really good stuff
I can anticipate the
reaction from the squishy right Wingers
the the the only criticism that I can
imagine but I bet you'll hear it
is oh come on this is
this is an overreach here this is now
what now it's the conservatives wielding
the government to to pass legislation
about gas stoves one way or the other
this is so crazy the federal government
shouldn't be talking about gas stoves
what a waste of time
to which I say
but the federal government is talking
about gas stoves
Ted Cruz and Joe manchin didn't start
this fight
the consumer product safety commission
started this fight
and the you might say well the federal
government has no right
to ban gas stoves yeah they don't but
they could
they could do it
federal government does all sorts of
stuff
and and this regulation Could Happen
don't you remember when the Democrats
tried to ban our incandescent light
bulbs and succeeded they succeeded so
for a while I think when was this around
2008 2010 somewhere in there the Dems
banned incandescent light bulbs also
known as the nice light bulbs the warm
beautiful light bulbs and they made
everyone use those those hideous
fluorescent bulbs that are really ugly
they they're they're unpleasant on the
eyes they're filled with Mercury or LEDs
which are also unpleasant on the eyes
you think these are minor issues but
they're not minor issues they're major
major issues any conservative who
believes that
culture matters at all who thinks that
politics is about more than just
marginal tax rates
we'll have to admit
that light bulbs
and gas stoves are some of the most
important issues in the country why is
that because they affect it pretty much
every moment of our day
and we're not even conscious of it
that's why they're so important too is
because we're not even aware consciously
of what light bulbs are like but they
they affect the way we feel the way we
view the world our perceptions of
Aesthetics all the time Christopher
Alexander the architect and
Architectural theorist he pointed out
that when you go into a space it will
always either
slightly raise or slightly lower your
spirits but it won't be neutral nothing
is neutral
if I can if I can insist upon one point
from this entire show not just this
episode I mean this whole show
it is that nothing is neutral in this
world
things are either a little bit better a
little bit worse a little bit truer a
little bit false or a little bit more
beautiful a little bit uglier
a little bit more for God or a little
bit more for the guy that Sam Smith was
dressed up at the other night
and so we we need to we need to engage
in these sorts of decisions we need to
recognize that these cultural issues
matter all the Libs ever tell us is oh
who cares about the bathrooms who cares
if a man goes into the girl's bathroom
it's not a big deal oh who cares about
the Chinese weather balloon oh who cares
about vaccine side effects who cares
about the light bulbs who cares about
the gas stoves I care because that's my
culture
if you say who cares who cares who cares
long enough about every single aspect of
my culture then you're going to
completely upend my culture
and I love that Cruz and Mansion are not
letting this one slip by
they're saying no you we you get to keep
your gas stove okay you get to keep it
now the meanwhile the other Republicans
are just completely completely clueless
I got into I'll keep this brief because
it's just a response to some reaction
against something I said on the show the
other day I pointed out that
it is very silly for the GOP to offer a
second response to the State of the
Union in Spanish
and we've got one response from Sarah
Sanders that's bad enough because
whoever gives us the response to the
State of the Union usually harms their
political career because you don't have
the Grandeur of being in Congress to
actually deliberate like the president
does
but now we're giving a second one in
Spanish and the guy who's giving it he's
this Congressman with six kids seems
like a great guy
but the message that it sends is so bad
some conservatives have said Michael
who cares what you you don't want people
to speak other languages please focus on
something that matters we're going to
reach out to the Hispanics I love people
who speak other languages I speak other
languages myself I go to church in
another language okay I I'm I'm all for
that
but this is the state of the union this
is supposed to be an event that unites
us as a nation it's both houses of
Congress in in meeting in the same
chamber it's the Democrats and the
Republicans it's the members of the
Supreme Court even show up it's all of
us tuning in it's supposed to unite us
and in this country we have very very
little that unites us anymore
when the ordinary means that unite
Nations include religion ideology
race shared experience like the
experience of a war
epistemology even the the idea that at
this point in America we can't even
agree on how we can know things at all
you've got half the country who is is
worshiping Dr fauci and says that if a
guy in a white lab coat doesn't say it
it isn't true and then you've got half
the country remember is that actually
you know we can know certain things
Beyond just what what crooked
technocrats tell us
we don't we have very little that unites
us the basic thing the most the only
thing left is language and in a
self-governing republic language is
essential because that's how we govern
ourselves we speak and we persuade one
another and we pass legislation if you
don't speak the same language which is
the premise here the premise is there's
a lot of people in America who don't
speak English that's a problem we
shouldn't be catering to that we should
be discouraging that
but instead what do we have we have the
Republicans saying no it's a muy bueno
that we're going to go out here and
talking in espanol and the Democrats
they're they're real racists and and
Spanish phobes and you see Joe Biden
giving a speech in Spanish tonight I
don't think so I hope not
but we're the ones doing it because we
think that maybe we'll pick up a few
extra voters
Republicans have done a decent enough
job on the Hispanic vote recently
though I think actually more of the
victory in Florida is probably explained
by just millions of new Republicans
leaving States like California and
moving into Florida but we've done a
good job with Hispanic voters I love
Hispanic voters I think it's great I
even like the Spanish language I even
like Spanish Literature but not at my
state of the union this is America speak
English good grief have speak any common
life make it Latin I don't know that'd
be fun let's maybe that can be our
common language but make it a Common
Language
for all speaking around languages we're
all we're we are only going to further
the the
self-obsessed chaos that has enveloped
our entire country it's crazy head on
over to dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]